generalmente usamos dos formas para
nombrar a los saludos de alquiló o
también conocidos como halogenuros de
alquilo empecemos con la más común
primero pensemos en el grupo alquiló en
este caso podemos ver que tenemos un
grupo estilo tiene dos carbonos entonces
escribimos etil y como es una loro o
halogenuro de alquilo necesitamos saber
que a lo que no tenemos presente y su
nombre llevará la terminación 1
entonces como aquí tenemos al cloro este
es el cloruro de etilo cloruro de etilo
ese es el nombre de este compuesto y
ahora nombremos a la misma molécula pero
esta vez usando la nomenclatura iupac en
este caso será nombrada como una lo
alcan entonces aun alcano de 2 carbonos
se le conoce como eta no entonces
escribimos ésta
y claro ya sabemos que nuestro halógeno
es el cloro así que el nombre de este
compuesto es cloro et al cloro etano y
si tuviéramos flúor entonces sería flúor
o eta no lo escribiré aquí flúor
observen cómo se escribe y si en lugar
de cloro tuviéramos bromo entonces sería
bromo etam y finalmente si en lugar de
cloro tuviéramos yodo entonces sería
yodo etano yodo ok ahora nombremos este
compuesto usando el sistema común
nuevamente primero pensemos en el grupo
alquiló en otro vídeo vimos que este es
el grupo iso pro pilot entonces
escribimos y su propio y nuevamente
tenemos un cloro unido a este grupo así
que usando el sistema común
este es el cloruro
cloruro de isopropílico
y si ahora lo nombramos usando el
sistema upac primero buscamos la cadena
de carbonos más larga que aquí es de 1 2
3 y sabemos que eso es propano entonces
escribimos propano y podemos ver que
tenemos un cloro unido al carbono 2 por
lo tanto sería 2 cloro propano ok ahora
veamos cómo podemos clasificar a los
saludos de alquilo para eso simplemente
observamos el carbono que está unido
directamente a nuestro halógeno y
contamos cuántos grupos al kilo están
unidos a ese carbono por ejemplo aquí
sólo hay un grupo al kilo unido a este
carbono el metil entonces este es un
alumno de alquilo primario el cloruro de
tilo es un excelente ejemplo de un
alumno de alquilo primario y si ahora
observamos el cloruro de isopropílico
que tenemos aquí abajo podemos ver que
este carbono está
y 22 grupos alquilo por lo tanto es un
alumno de alquilo secundario y déjenme
dibujar otro ejemplo rápidamente
ok para este compuesto el carbono que
está unido a nuestro halógeno también
está unido a tres grupos alquilo en este
caso a tres grupos metilo así que este
es un alero de alquilo terciario y el
nombre común de este compuesto es
cloruro de termo tilo y es con el que
seguramente más se van a encontrar y
bueno para las moléculas largas
generalmente es más fácil usar el
sistema iupac entonces nombremos a este
compuesto usando el sistema iupac que es
como nombrar a los arcanos primero
necesitamos encontrar la cadena de
carbonos más larga que en este caso es
de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 carbonos y sabemos que
un al que no de 7 carbonos es un eta no
entonces escribimos
después pensemos en cómo enumerar esta
cadena de carbonos empezamos por la
izquierda o por la derecha bueno primero
empecemos por la izquierda tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 6 y 7
entonces si iniciamos por el lado
izquierdo
tenemos un bromo unido al carbono 2 un
metil en el carbono 4 y otro metil en el
carbono 5 entonces tenemos algo en 2 4 y
5 y ahora intentemos numerar el mismo
compuesto pero empezando la numeración
por el lado derecho entonces este es el
carbono 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 así tenemos un
metil unido al carbono 3 otro metil en
el carbono 4 y un bromo en el carbono 6
entonces 3 4 y 6 y nuestro objetivo es
asignarle el número más pequeño posible
al primer sustituye ente del lado
izquierdo el número más pequeño es 2 y
del lado derecho tenemos 3
obviamente 2 es menor a 3 así que nos
vamos a quedar con la numeración del
lado izquierdo y ya identifica
a nuestros sustituyen t es verdad ya
sabemos que tenemos bromo y dos grupos
metilo eso le da el nombre dimetil y
también necesitamos pensar en el orden
alfabético entonces como el bromo va
primero y después va el dimetil vamos a
escribir dimetil y sabemos que nuestros
metilo se encuentran en el carbono 4 y 5
esos números nos ayudan a identificar en
donde se encuentran los grupos metilo y
después tenemos un bromo en el carbono 2
entonces escribimos 2 brom así que el
nombre completo iupac es 2 bromo 4,5
dimetil están ok y ahora nombremos este
compuesto hagamos lo mismo que antes 1 2
3 4 5 6
nuevamente tenemos un ept ano y ahora
empezamos la numeración desde la
izquierda o desde la derecha bueno si
escribimos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 así tenemos
un grupo metilo unido al carbono 2 otro
grupo metilo en el carbono 5 y un bromo
también en el carbono 5 entonces para
este caso sería 255 y del lado derecho
tenemos el mismo compuesto pero ahora
vamos a empezar la numeración desde el
lado derecho para ver si así obtenemos
números más pequeños
entonces de esta forma tenemos al bromo
en el carbono 3 un metil también en el 3
y otro metil en el carbono 6 entonces 3
3 y 6
otra vez gana la numeración de la
derecha porque 2 es menor a 3 y nuestro
objetivo es tener el número más pequeño
posible para el primer sustituye ente
entonces
usar la numeración por el lado izquierdo
tenemos un grupo metilo en el carbono 2
y en el 5 nuevamente como en el ejemplo
anterior tenemos dos grupos metilo que
dan el nombre dimetil vamos a escribir
dimetil y esta vez tenemos un metilo en
el carbono 2 y en el 5 entonces
escribimos 2,5 y finalmente tenemos un
bromo en el carbono 5 entonces 5 brom
así que el nombre completo es 5 promo 25
y metano
ahora nombremos a este compuesto primero
contamos los carbonos de la cadena más
larga 1 2 3 4 5 y a una cadena de 5
carbonos se le conoce como pentano
entonces escribimos ventana y ahora
vamos a pensar en cómo enumerar la
cadena de carbonos para que el primer
sustituye ente tenga el número menor
posible entonces si iniciamos la
numeración del lado izquierdo
aquí el bromo está en el carbono número
1 y esa es la mejor forma de enumerar lo
entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4 y 5 entonces
tenemos un grupo metilo en el carbono 4
un cloro en el carbono 3 y un bromo en
el carbono 1 y ahora necesitamos
escribirlos en orden alfabético así que
primero va el bromo después el cloro y
después el metil entonces vamos a
escribir el metil que se encuentra en el
carbono 4
y después tenemos el cloro en el carbono
3 entonces sería 3 cloro y finalmente el
bromo que lo tenemos en el carbono 1
entonces uno bromo por lo tanto el
nombre completo es uno bromo 3 cloro 4
metil pentano
ahora veamos este compuesto aquí tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 6 carbonos en la cadena más
larga y aún al que no de 6 carbonos se
le conoce como hexano entonces
escribimos hexano y aquí tenemos 2
sustituye entes tenemos bromo y un grupo
metilo entonces primero iniciemos la
numeración desde la izquierda y veamos
qué pasa 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 de esta forma
tenemos al bromo en el carbono 2 y al
metilo en el 5 pero ahora vamos a
iniciar la numeración por el lado
derecho
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 de esta forma
tenemos al metilo en el carbono 2 y al
bromo en el carbono 5 entonces si
analizamos los números no podemos saber
quién gana porque tenemos 2 contra 2 y 5
contra 5 es un empate pero
forma de romper ese empate es pensar en
el orden alfabético de nuestros
sustituye entes
aquí tenemos bromo y metil tenemos b
contra m
y claro b va antes que m en el alfabeto
así que el bromo gana le daremos al
bromo el número más pequeño por lo tanto
usaremos la numeración del ejemplo de la
izquierda en la que el bromo se
encuentra en el carbono 2 entonces
elegimos la numeración de la cadena
principal de carbonos de la izquierda y
eso significa que tenemos un metilo en
el carbono 5 entonces 5 metil y el bromo
se encuentra en el carbono 2 entonces 2
brom así que el nombre completo de este
compuesto es 2 promo 5 metí lexan ahora
qué hacemos si tenemos estéreo química
en nuestro compuesto bueno primero vamos
a ignorar la estéreo química y vamos a
nombrar el compuesto como lo haríamos
normalmente primero encontramos la calle
principal de carbonos que en este caso
es de 1 2 3 y 4 carbonos por lo tanto
tenemos butano vamos a escribir lo
butano y queremos numerar la cadena de
tal forma que nuestro sustituye entes se
encuentren en el menor número posible
entonces escribimos 1 2 3 y 4 así como
en este caso nuestro sustituye ente es
el bromo se encuentra en el carbono 2
por lo tanto el nombre de esta molécula
es 2 bromo gotham pero ahora vamos a ver
la estéreo química sabemos que aquí
tenemos un centro que ir al y sabemos
que hay un hidrógeno lejos de nosotros
porque el bromo se encuentra hacia
nosotros y ahora vamos a asignar la
prioridad a esos 4 grupos que están
unidos a nuestro centro que irán
sabemos que el bromo como tiene el
número atómico más alto tiene la
prioridad más alta
que este grupo es el número uno después
el grupo de tilo tiene la prioridad
número 2
el grupo metilo tiene la prioridad
número 3 y finalmente este hidrógeno que
está lejos de nosotros tiene la
prioridad más baja del grupo es el
número 4 entonces tenemos 1 2 y 3 en el
sentido de las manecillas del reloj por
lo tanto la configuración es r entre
paréntesis vamos a poner r y así nos
queda que el nombre iupac de este
compuesto es r 2 bromo butano